hello everyone and every Naga by Shuba
and I'm a postdoc at Cambridge
University and today I will be speaking
about machine learning and how we can
apply these algorithms to something
actually very useful in cancer research
first a little disclaimer I'm not a
biologist I know a lot about the
mathematics I know a lot about the
algorithms but I don't know that much
about biology so if any of you has a
biological background I apologize I'll
be making a lot of simplifications so I
think every talk about genomics and
cancer research has to tell you
something about the scale of the problem
so actually this is a photo from a
psychopath that starts about 200 meters
from where I work at Research Hospital
and it has these little nice little
stripes that actually represents the
base pairs in a DNA and this bike path
is only about one and half my long 11.6
actually and it represents one gene
bracketry gene I will be talking about
that a bit later but it contains ten
thousand base pairs so just to give you
idea of the scale of the whole problem
when we are looking at DNA if we were to
make a path like this for our whole DNA
sequence how long do you think it would
be anyone has a guess it would actually
go around the whole earth 20 times so
that's the ultimate big data basically
and another problem we have to face is
that the first original DNA sequence the
whole human DNA sequence was read in
2003 and the cost was 100 billion
dollars but the cost has been slowly
going down and then we changed
methodologies and now this is actually
quite an old graph now it's about 1
thousand dollars per human genome so now
it's getting quite realistic that when
you have some kind of problem you will
go to see a doctor they will take a
sample of your tissue and send it for
sequencing so we are getting to this
stage where it's getting real exciting
but the problem right now is that the
data are really really big and it's
estimated that in a couple of years
actually the number of the amount of DNA
sequencing you'll have to store will be
larger than YouTube will be harder than
data that astronomical X that's particle
physics collides so it's getting to be a
very exciting area for research and for
applications and we have a lot of
problems that we have to deal with
anyway a little bit about the biology
just a little bit this is our DNA
sequence very large one and it's sort of
like a stable code that encodes
everything that's happening in our cells
in our bodies and we don't want to mess
up with a stable code that encodes
everything so if the cell actually wants
to do anything it needs to copy part of
that sequence to sympathise proteins and
the part of DNA that encodes proteins
are called genes so when the cell wants
to do something basically unzipped the
double helix and reads part of the code
that encodes a protein and transport it
out of the cell and this is very useful
in research because if we want to see
what the cell is doing what's happening
there at any single point we can look at
the amount of these RNA molecules that
are copying the information from DNA and
that gives us a lot of information about
what's happening there at any given time
so this was a little bit about biology
and now a little about cancer cancer is
ultimately a disease caused by mutations
in the DNA code if some error happens
there there are some mechanisms to
correct it most
the time but some of the times the error
is so substantial that the cell starts
growing without limits proliferating and
then it becomes a cancer and you know
there are some genes that serve as error
correcting agents and these are the
genes Broca one and braca tool which
bracha two is actually the gene that's
based on the psychopath and they are
trying to correct errors that happen
during DNA replication
so if cell is dividing it needs to
create two copies of the DNA and these
two genes how to ensure that this
happens correctly if it doesn't happen
correctly then they initiate cell death
and it's so dies in a normal tissue but
when something happens then the cell
starts growing without any limits and
and becomes cancer and these two genes
are actually very important in breast
cancer these genes if they are in their
normal form they guard against cancer
there are tumor suppressors but if they
have mutations then they cause cancer
basically because they are not able to
correctly discard the cells that are not
dividing well and these two genes are
important in breast cancer because if
you have the mutated variant of these
genes then you have about 70%
probability you will get cancer during
your life I guess you have heard about
Angelina Jolie who had double mastectomy
because she had the mutated variant of
these two genes but what I'm trying to
say here is that cancer is ultimately
not a single disease in it has the same
mechanism that happens through DNA
modifications and mutations but it's
ultimately a group of diseases that
behave similarly in one way and
differently because they are caused by
different mutations so now we will move
more to the area of machine learning how
to actually find out from data from
sample
from patients what type of disease they
have and for that we can use algorithm
mastering who here has done any machine
learning quite a lot of people so I
guess you are familiar with clustering
clustering is just about finding groups
in data that are more similar among
themselves and less similar against each
other so first the simple application of
clustering this is just very simple data
set with customers wholesale customers
buying products from big retailer and
that's just publicly available data set
I think it's from Portugal and the
customers were buying fresh produce milk
products like cheese grocery products
frozen food detergents and paper and etc
so I ran a very simple clustering
algorithm on that and it identified two
main groups of customers here and this
is a projection from space of these six
data points to just a two-dimensional
space and actually the red group here
corresponds to hotels that buy much more
paper products than normal
customers and the blue one represents
normal restaurants and retailers so this
is just a simple example of clustering
and how can we use this in cancer
research well if we map the customers to
genes and if we map what products are
the customers buying onto a gene
expression that means the amount of RNA
in the cell for each gene then we can
basically cluster them again and obtain
quite a lot of information about type of
the disease and specific patients and we
can apply that in this setting this is
like a conventional medicine setting
where if you are diagnosed with the
disease you get some kind of treatment
that's the standard way that it's
happening usually so if you are
diagnosed with
breast cancer or prostate cancer you
would get chemotherapy or surgery but
what we really want is to identify and
stratify the people into the groups they
form based on the type of their disease
because even if you take the breast
cancer it's not a single disease it can
be caused by different mutations and
then it leads to different outcomes and
some of them can be really really
dangerous and very aggressive and other
types can be quite mild and you can live
with them for years so what we really
want to is to find subgroups of patients
that react to different treatments
because they have different starts of
the disease so this is actually a
picture from my PhD thesis where I was
doing clustering of gene expression data
on breast cancer and this is a
projection from the space of about 700
genes into two dimensional space and
each of these groups represent group of
patients that react differently to
treatments and they have different
survival outcomes and what we can
actually do with clustering what was
actually the point of my PhD thesis was
to create more complicated algorithms
for clustering that integrate multiple
different types of data together because
gene expression gives us just one view
of the whole process of cancer but we
can look at micro RNA expression protein
expression in cells and extract clusters
from all these types of data put
together so this was just to give you
some idea about how we can use
clustering so now we have groups of
patients that have different outcomes
that react differently to treatments and
what can we do now is actually how to
find what characterizes these patients
and how to find out what mutations are
important in which kind of cancer so for
this we can use another type of machine
learning algorithms which is called
cooperative filtering and it's used
quite a lot in recomm
systems so I guess everyone has heard
about the Netflix prize who hasn't heard
about the Netflix prize this actually
started in 2006 before all machine
learning algorithms all the machine
learning competitions were not there yet
and Netflix gave price of 1 million
dollars for anyone who manages to
improve their recommender system by 10
percent and the prize was awarded in
2009 ultimately but the problem in
simplified form was that they had a
matrix where on one side they had users
and on the other side they had found
movies and they had rating for each user
the film they watched they gave them a
rating between 1 and 5 stars and the
task is to predict the missing values
because this matrix is very very sparse
because most people didn't see most of
the films but you want to recommend what
user should watch based on their past
behavior and based on their similarity
to other users so the base of the
algorithm that was used to actually win
the Netflix prize was collaborative
filtering through matrix factorization
now the cysts a little bit of algebra
but this is the original matrix wherein
had users on one side and the ratings on
the other so it was a very big sparse
matrix and what we can do to actually
solve the problem of filling in the
missing information in the matrix is
that we can basically split it into a
product of two smaller matrices now we
have small matrix for users and smaller
matrix for movies and this movie matrix
corresponds is has the number of columns
the same as the rating matrix and the
user matrix has the same number of
columns sorry number of rows as their
rating matrix so if we multiply these
two matrices we get the original rating
matrix only with the missing
nation filled in and that's very useful
right it's quite complicated to actually
compute this because it's the matrices
are very very large and if you want to
impose some other constraints onto the
matrix like just non-negative values to
be able to interpret it easily then it
becomes quite complicated but anyway
this is the basic idea and what it
actually does is that it projects users
onto some kind of subspace where each
row in this matrix characterizes the
user it summarizes what they like to
watch and how they rate the films and
this matrix characterizes the movies if
it's an action movie if it's a romance
it gets summarized in this matrix so
this holds quite a lot of information
and how can we use it in cancer research
again we can map the users to patients
with their specific types of cancer and
we can map their rating to the mutations
that occur for each user because one
part of the problem with cancer is that
most of the mutations appear only in
minority of people that means there are
a few mutations that are very common but
the rest of them are very very sparse so
it kind of corresponds to the Netflix
price so this is just an example of the
matrix where we have mutations and the
mutations are basically single point
mutations see mutates to a see mutates
to G etc and again we can use the
collaborative filtering to extract on
one hand the characteristics of patients
based on their mutations and then we can
also extract signatures for different
different types of cancer and then
people who design drugs can actually
look at these results and see what
cancers are characterized by what
mutations and for example the C entity
mutations
very characteristic for environmental
damage for example through smoking so if
you smoke you get many more mutations of
the type C 2 T and T 2 C which is
interesting and it can help design drugs
in the end so this was another example
of a machine learning algorithm applied
to cancer research data and because
these algorithms are routinely applied
to recommender systems for millions of
users it's capable enough to apply it to
genomic data which is great but when we
actually get this type of information
what can we do with it later can we
actually do something to design drugs
through well this won't be about machine
learning itself it will be more about
verifications and proving but it can use
the information extracted through
machine learning in the earlier stages
so can we actually use it to see how can
we disrupt the process of cancer and for
this I'm afraid another formal thing
this is just simple boolean
satisfiability formula I guess you have
scenes and things like that so this is
it contains variables a and B that can
be either true or false and we can get
conjunctions and negations etc so this
is satisfiable if a is true and B is
true and we can use similar ideas to
actually construct a model of a
biological system we will need a little
more complicated model for that and it's
will be the SMT explain that later but
if we actually replace the variables a
and B with some small formulas that
evaluates to true or false we can then
use simple methods to prove it and
actually this becomes a program called
the
five building modular theories and this
formula is satisfiable if a is equal to
4 and B is equal to zero so we can
actually use even numbers in this kind
of problem and I wanted to show you this
in a practical setting who here has seen
a sharp before Oh quite a lot of people
nice so this is actually a program in F
sharp and I'll be using the Z 3 prover
it's a fear improver that's used quite a
lot of in systems verification software
verification so I just wanted to show
you a simple example of the proving
method
Wow I'll be looking at a very simple
problem
I took my chain you want to pay some
price for something you are a shop and
you want to pay something and you want
to see what's the minimum number of
nodes you need to give the wreckage here
to actually pay the price so let's just
evaluate this in case you haven't seen
em sharp there is a code in the upper
half and it's evaluated here in
something called F sharp interactive
which is a wrapper so I will just create
a context for the proof and I'm creating
two nodes a $1 note and $5 note and
that's like an integer created in the
context and then I will create two
constants in the environment and one of
them represents the multiplier for the
first banknote and the other one is
multiplier for the second node and what
we want to see is if we can what's the
minimum number of nodes we can use so
how to actually compute the price we
will just put together three formulas so
what we do is we multiply the first
variable by one it's the one dollar note
then we multiply the second variable by
five that's the number of $5 notes and
then we sum the whole thing so far so
easy right and we also want to see how
many notes we are using in total so this
is another expression that basically
just sums the two multipliers so just
show you an example with ten notes and
thirty-two dollars in total so I will
create a solver and I will add
constraints which tell me that the sum
of the all values should be equal to the
value I want to pay and the number of
notes should be equal to the number of
notes I have and now I can run the sober
and it returned satisfiable so I can
actually print the result and you can
see that this formula is satisfiable for
two $1 notes and 5a and eight $5 notes
that's very easy isn't it but what's
really nice is that it can contain
things like integer values it can
contain equality's inequalities we can
put an implications things like that
yeah now we can also make it a bit nicer
with something called quotations in a
chart which basically allow me to write
the expression I'm interested in as this
sort of function and it returns the
function as sort of syntax tree of the
evaluation so now here I have the syntax
tree and I know that it's a function of
two values that cause equality between
one expression and another expression so
I will just wrap it in a simple function
that tests this for different numbers of
banknotes and just to show you how fast
it is
let's say we are interested in how to
play 2042 dollars with one and five
dollar bills and I will be trying to
satisfy this formula with different
values of K which is the number of nodes
I have and oh no you can see that it's
very clever because it's at its
unsatisfiable for K equals 1 but its
satisfiable for 2 nodes if I pay 510 $1
node and the cash she returns 508 then
835 oh that's that doesn't look right so
we should add another constraint that I
have here that actually says that the
multipliers must be larger than 0 so
this only goes through variables that I
have in my model and add constraints
that they must be greater or equal than
0 so everything again
and let's find the value and it's
unsatisfiable for a lot of different
combinations but finally it took about
three seconds to find it and you can
satisfy it with 410 banknotes that's the
smallest number so this was to give you
some idea about this verification system
and how can we actually apply this now
in general people use it for software
verification where they transform the
sorts of conditions that should hold
about code into SMT formulas and an
example this is spec sharp which is a
software verification tool for c-sharp
where you take your C sharp code and add
some kind of requirements about it so
this is just a simple function that
tries to swap two values in an array so
what we what are the preconditions for
this function is that the I must be
larger than or equal to zero and it must
be smaller than the length etc so this
is a condition that has to hold for this
code to work so if you want to run this
code in big program that uses spec chart
you the program has to prove that
actually these conditions hold for the
function to be able to run and the same
ideas are used for verification for
example I think Airbus uses solver to do
the same type of verification in their
software so how can we use it in cancer
research well now all these functions
and conditions in the code turn into
proteins and genes and receptors and
they become variables in our SMT
formulas and what should happen in a
biological system is that if you have a
value of some variable for example
activity of a gene then based on its
environment it can either increase
decrease or stay the same and we can
translate this into this verification
type of problem where we have some true
value or a target value for each of
these variables and we are looking for
an evaluation of the system that is
stable that means if variable has some
kind of value if it's equal to its
target value then it states the same if
it's not equal to n the system changes
and what we can do is actually encode
the whole problem in this type of
formulation and I have an example here
which is so-called DMA model it's by a
model analyzer and it's been developed
by some of my colleagues in the Cancer
Research Institute and these are this is
an example of a skin layer with five
cells and it's a simple biological
system and still it's quite complicated
you can get skin cancer right and skin
cancer happens when the cells are
growing more than they are dying and the
standard skin you basically cells are
created then they go through some kind
of process and they are dying in the end
and then they fall off your skin and if
they are growing more than they are
dying off that means you get skin cancer
so even model like this can model the
sort of situation and the analyzer can
find a stable solution for this if it
stabilizes that means that you have
normal skin if it doesn't stabilize that
means you might get skin cancer and this
actually uses F sharp underneath and
this model basically tries to prove if
the system stabilizes or not and can
give you some information about how it
stabilizes and what are the target
values for each variable so
actually my colleague Ben Hall and the
MRC cancer unit use this to show
stability of leukemia this is chronic
myeloid leukemia which is very simple
well the cause of this disease is very
simple it happens where two chromosomes
chromosome number nine and chromosome
number 22 exchange parts and what
happens is that this chromosome loses
this end and it attaches to this
chromosome instead so that's an error in
copying chromosomes and what happens
here the problem is that there are
proteins at the boundaries where this
exchange happens and if you get this
type of chromosome it will starts
producing the wrong protein and then you
get this type of leukemia and they
actually modeled this type of disease in
the analyzer that uses the system
verification proofs they collected
information from literature and they put
in all the constraints and all the
relations that are supposed to be there
and then they were looking at how stable
the system is and turns out if you have
this type of leukemia unfortunately it
is very stable that means if you disrupt
just one gene or one receptor or one
protein then the system still holds and
the disease is still there so this tells
us something about the design of drugs
for this type of disease we can't start
at just one gene or one protein because
it doesn't destabilize the whole system
in the cell but if we targets pairs of
genes or pairs of proteins then actually
the system can become unstable and that
means that the cell will die which is a
very nice application of this type of
problem because it can prove what will
happen
if we change something so this has quite
a lot of application probably in the
future for drug design and also to find
insights about if we know enough about
what's happening in the cell because if
we don't specify all the relations that
are there then the system won't
stabilize that means there is something
happening there that we don't know much
about so I hope this gave you a little
bit of insight into some machine
learning algorithms sometimes when you
read articles on the internet it seems
that machine learning is only about
advertising or about algorithmic trading
or about extracting personal information
about people but actually machine
learning can be used in a lot of
different areas and by informatics and
systems biology is one of them and I
think it's a really exciting area to be
in right now because more and more data
are becoming available and it will
become more and more important in the
future so I think I went a bit too
quickly but if you want to contact me
these are some of the details and also
if you are interested in some of the
actual things I was talking about I will
give the slides on the internet and
there are some links that can tell you a
bit more okay thank you